earlier today President Trump praised
the cooperation between France in the
United States and standing up to the
mullahs in Tehran as well as fighting
Isis radicals take a look from earlier
France in the United States also agree
that Iran cannot be allowed to develop a
nuclear weapon and that regime must end
its support of terrorism all over
nowhere no matter where you go in the
Middle East you see the fingerprints of
I ran behind problems I also want to
thank president McCrone for France's
vital contribution to our very
successful campaign against Isis here
with reaction former deputy assistant to
the president and Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka and
NRA TV contributor former Secret Service
agent Dan bonds you know all across Asia
you see this really you see all these
relationships the Prime Minister of
Japan the president of China
capitulating on intellectual property
rights on on trade on automobiles on
tariffs you see what was unspeakable dr.
korkor an amazing alliance to combat
Iranian hegemony between the United
States Israel the Saudis the Emirates
the Jordanians Egyptians unthinkable in
the Obama years and all of this in just
15 months I mean think about what he's
achieved we we have NATO we have the
French prime minister within minutes of
meeting the president on this state
visit saying you want us to spend more
on our defense to stop being freeloaders
you've got it
the NATO secretary-general has done the
same that's after decades of freeloading
inside NATO we've seen Isis decimated in
terms of the physical Caliphate we've
seen all of our friends and allies
reassured in Asia it goes on and on and
on it's really quite stunning that these
are the kinds of results that you would
be proud of as a president at the end of
your second term maybe at the end of
your first term but not at the end of
your very very first term the idea just
the idea
that Sunni States Arab Sunni states are
now cooperating hand in glove with
Israel to deal with the threat of jihadi
violence in Amal is stunning and it's
interesting that as the president
isolated North Korea we saw damn Mangino
what the North Koreans did and the
relationship the good relationship that
President Trump had with the president
of China now played a big part in all of
this and and acquiescing on major issues
now you see the same thing happening the
Alliance created against the Iranian
mullahs very different approach than
than backing up a hundred and fifty
billion in cash and other currencies and
cargo planes yes Shawn I think one of
trumps assets has been his
unpredictability now listen you can
chalk that up to whatever you want I
mean the left-leaning hacks and the
media have been taking potshots at Trump
on his foreign policy forever you know
Sebastian's right they mocked him over
his approach to NATO until these
countries started making larger
commitments to NATO
they not they mocked him over his
approach to North Korea oh he's going to
get us into nuclear war now the North
Koreans are coming to the table with at
least talks I don't want to oversell it
for denuclearization you can't deny the
fact John that his relationship with
China the economic pressure he put on
China due to his tariffs threat probably
had something to do with this but you
know it's really I mean honestly it's
sad as an American to watch the media
and not all there's a few of them who've
kind of come around a little bit on this
but most of them just continue to mock
this guy as some kind of a buffoon as he
runs rings around what Obama did in
eight years all right I want to thank
you both incredible night incredible
opportunity for the world too
appeasement never works peace through
strength works again we saw it with
Neville Chamberlain versus Winston
Churchill all the people that were
against Ronald Reagan and we see it
working here Obama's appeasement didn't
work Clinton's appeasement didn't work
unbelievable all right